a cena que me deu acho que foi a que me
deu mais medo foi quando essa menina
caiu no chão que ela ficou olhando Sabe
aquela cena que dá silêncio que você
observa em cada canto da tela do cinema
em cada canto dessa tela você fica
procurando um erro tem alguma coisa
caminhando por ali o que que vai
acontecer agora você observando tudo
aquele silêncio você fica pensando ei ah
desgraça me me caguei todinho não foi
nem o demônio foi uma poa do nada a
menina a filha do cara vem caminhando
assim que nem o demônio sabe o demônio
gosta de botar as pernas para cima para
um lado e pro outro assim e vomita o
negócio preto na boca dela aí pronto daí
pra frente essa menina parece feliz 24
horas por dia por isso que eu desconfio
de gente feliz demais fica aí essa dica
para você aí viem a parte que eu fico
indignado o pai da menina vai lá tá lá a
menina Jantando com a Annabelle qual é
que é a menina a menina do problema na
perna que tá feliz 24 horas por dia aí
ela começa se transformar no demônio
assim ó fazend assim ó vai se quebrando
assim ó e virando o demônio assim ó
assim ó ó ó que o demônio dança break el
vai só assim ó
uh